And she'd be in there
watching, like, novellas
with a scale,
a bag of coke, a gun,
and a motherfucking Chihuahua.
You understand?
Who fucking has
a Chihuahua for protection?
[dramatic music]
♪
[cheers and applause]
Thank you.
On this show,
here's what happens.
It's just a bunch of comics
telling true stories,
and that's all it is.
The man, the myth, the legend,
Mr. Joey Diaz.
[cheers and applause]
You know, when I was a kid,
my mom had a bar,
and she was popular, so she had
a lot of, like, girlfriends
that hung out with her,
like, hot girls.
But there was this one chick
that she used to
be kind of tight with, but
I couldn't fucking understand
what the friendship--like, they
would be on the phone all day.
They would talk
five times a day.
If my mother was in the city,
she would stop by her house.
And then as I got older,
I got the back story,
that they knew each other
in Cuba, and then...
This lady's name was Z.
That's what we're gonna call her
for this fucking story.
'Cause the names have changed
to protect the innocent,
all that shit.
So, uh, they came from Cuba,
and Z married some dude
and went to Chicago.
My mom opted--
went to New York.
And like six months
into the marriage,
the guy was beating
the hell out of Z,
and my mom and my dad
drove down there and saved her
in the middle of the night
and took her to New York.
And she was indebted to them.
And this is, like,
19-fucking-60.
Then, you know,
as long as I can remember,
my mom used to go over there.
And I liked going over
to where she lived
because she went on
to become a huge drug dealer
in New York.
Right?
On 113th and Fifth Avenue
in the mouth of Spanish
motherfucking Harlem, right?
And it was scary.
It was like The Walking Dead.
You see, like,
Puerto Ricans walking around.
People fucking nodding
on the sidewalks.
It was just amazing as
a little kid to see this.
Fuck the circus and the zoo.
These are real
fucking animals.
Like, hanging there.
Laying in their own puke
and shit.
It's fucking tremendous.
So, I liked going there, too,
'cause she'd always give me,
like, a 20 or a 50.
As young as I was,
she always dropped--
and she always did
a blast of coke,
no matter
where the fuck she was.
You understand me?
So I would go over there,
she'd pick me up, kiss me,
and then go in her bra.
[sniffs]
Do a line and ask me
how school was, and...
She went to my first communion.
She did a bump kneeling down
in the fucking thing.
She don't give a fuck!
That's a real crazy lady.
Not one of these ladies with a
tattoo and a hat with a feather.
"I'm so crazy."
No you're not, all right?
No you're not.
You go to yoga at Studio City.
You ain't that fucking crazy,
all right?
Fucking crazy.
Go to yoga in Compton, bitch,
and then we'll talk.
So going to her house, guys,
she lived on the second floor
over a bodega.
This is, like, the mid-'70s.
You know, you knocked
on Z's door,
and a black guy
opened the door,
and he'd point you
to the back.
And I would run to the back,
and she lived, like, in a--
like in--
she had, like, maybe
three rooms,
you know,
like a living room.
But where she sold
coke out of and heroin
was this little room that
had, like, beads in the front.
Like, you know,
you opened it up and shit.
And she'd be in there
watching, like, novellas
with a scale,
a bag of coke, a gun,
and a motherfucking Chihuahua.
You understand?
Who fucking has
a Chihuahua for protection?
And she was dark Cuban,
so she had big tits and an ass.
Like, she was good-looking,
but she had blonde hair
that was tight,
30 years before Lil' Kim.
I mean, she was way ahead of
her fucking time.
Finally, like, in the eighth or
ninth grade, I figured out,
you know,
they were just good friends.
They spoke all the time.
But then my dad--my mom died.
And she was
the first phone call I made.
And she was the first one there,
you know?
She made all
the funeral arrangements.
You motherfuckers been to
regular viewings with gentiles,
where they sit around and cry,
and it's like,
"Oh, he was such a great man."
That's great.
That--that's great.
Then there's
Irish fucking wakes,
where people are
drinking and cursing and--
But then there's Cuban wakes.
That makes an Irish wake look
like a fucking daycare, okay?
They drink 24--
and it's open 24 hours.
24 hours,
funeral parlor.
And anything goes.
People are doing lines,
people are arguing,
people playing dominoes.
People are playing
fucking dominoes
at my mother's fucking wake,
okay?
And the first night
I hear this commotion.
And I go in the hallway.
Z had the funeral director
by the throat
because she put the wrong dress
on my mother.
That is a fucking friend,
motherfuckers, right?
Like...'cause anybody can be
your fucking friend
when you're alive, but to
fucking be at your funeral
smacking motherfuckers,
right?
That's a friend, right?
[applause]
That's a fucking friend,
you know?
And she was checking people.
Like, "Hey, fuck you.
You didn't like her,
and she didn't fucking like you.
Get out."
She was checking people,
you know?
And all these people were
in there, "Oh, we loved Denore,"
and all this shit.
You didn't hear shit
from this lady.
You didn't hear a word.
There was no fakeness
out of her.
Right there,
I learned what fake was
and what real was.
At that early age,
I learned that, I saw it.
Like people come up to me,
"Oh, my God,
if you need anything..."
And after my mom died,
I'd call 'em,
and they changed
their fucking phone number.
But just little things
that I saw right then.
I decided, oh, my God,
that's what a fake person is.
"I loved your mother.
Oh, God, take me."
All that shit.
You know, the whole fucking
four days of the wake,
Z didn't say shit.
She would every once
in a while just sit in the back
and just take a little bump
out of her bra.
[sniffs]
And look at me and go, "Shh."
And she would just watch
what was going on.
Even--and she was
such a woman.
Like, men would be
having conversation.
I'm not talking
about regular fucking guys.
I'm talking about Latin,
old-school,
machismo motherfuckers.
And she would go tell 'em shit
like, "Shut the fuck up."
Like, even they were
scared of her.
And I observed all this,
like how she had taken over
for my mother.
And then the last night,
my mom got buried on a Monday,
and that Sunday
I went outside to smoke a joint
or whatever the fuck
you go outside of a wake for.
To get air.
And when I came back,
she was alone with my mother.
It was the first time
they were alone together.
And she was kneeling down,
and that's where I got it.
She was...petting her hair.
And she was telling her
how beautiful she was,
and how the world wasn't
gonna be the same without her,
and how she was gonna miss her,
and she was her sister.
And it was just
fucking mind-boggling.
And then she said--
and she turned,
like she knew I was there,
and she goes, "I'm gonna
take care of this motherfucker.
"I'm gonna take care of him,
I'm gonna watch over him,
I'm gonna make sure he
grows up to be a fucking man."
And I saw the meaning
of friendship right there,
when Z was petting her fucking
hair and doing bumps.
She did a fucking bump
right there, right?
She did a bump
looking at the casket.
She's like, "I'd give you one,
but what's the difference
at this point?"
But then it was after that
she stuck to her fucking word.
Every Sunday, she'd come over
from Long Island
and meet me
at Weehawken Cemetery,
and she'd bring
a bottle of Dewar's, flowers,
and she'd pour
the bottle of Dewar's out
and tell my mother how much she
loved her and she missed her,
and she'd do some bumps.
And by that time,
I was doing coke.
And she would, like, do bumps
into the spirit, like,
"Here's a couple for you."
And I'd be like,
"No! Let me...
Give them fucking things
to me!"
[laughter]
You're gonna fucking
throw 'em on the grass.
That's $20
of fucking blast there.
$20, $20, $20.
Stop it already!
Give it to me!
So...this went on.
She took care of me, guys,
from '79 till '83,
till I got out of high school.
Every fucking Sunday,
200 fucking beans.
And she'd bring me weed,
a little $5 nickel bag
from the city.
And then in '83
I moved to Colorado,
and, you know, I got into
craziness and shit.
But I always called her
twice a week.
I would send her pictures,
you know?
And then I moved
back to Jersey,
and by that time
I was a fucking lunatic.
You know, and the cocaine
had absorbed me and stuff.
And I kept in touch with her,
and I would go into the city
once a week
and take her
for a Cuban sandwich.
There was a place
on 118th Street, we'd walk.
And I went--
And I went to Miami,
and I found some friend of hers,
and I beat 'em for,
like, a half a kilo.
And I just felt fucking bad.
You know how it is, dog.
One bump leads into another.
Next thing you know,
you're having a party.
you did six ounces of blow.
It's a fucking nightmare,
you know what I'm saying?
And there's no rehabs.
There's no hugs.
You know?
'Cause they don't give a fuck,
you know?
That's it.
So I felt embarrassed.
And I came back from Miami and
I'd fucked these people over.
And I felt embarrassed,
so I didn't call her.
I didn't call her for,
like, five months.
And in January of '85,
I finally got a little sober
and I called her one day
and I go, "Z, what's going on?"
And she's like,
"Where the fuck have you been?"
She goes, "You haven't called me
in, like, five months."
She goes, "The cops raided me.
They took everything."
She goes, "My leg broke, and
there was nobody here for me."
And I felt fucking terrible.
I let my mother down,
I let myself down,
I let Z down.
And I was at a pay phone.
I just dropped
the fucking pay phone.
It was like
a kick in my stomach,
like she had just said,
you know,
"Where the fuck
were you for me?
"For all those years,
I was there for you,
and you just
disappeared on me."
And I was--I just felt terrible,
and I--
I walked away
from the pay phone.
I didn't call her
for about a week or two,
and then I finally called
and her phone was disconnected.
And I went over to the bodega
a few times,
and they told me
that she got busted
and they closed the apartment,
and I never talked to her again.
And I felt like shit.
And I live with that today.
And that 1985, you know?
And I thought about it,
and I digested it,
and I swore to God that if
I ever had a chance
to be a friend to somebody--
'Cause you don't need
20 friends.
You just need
three motherfuckers,
and you can
take over a country.
Okay, that's where we're
confused as Americans.
We think we need
all these motherfuckers.
You give me
three bad motherfuckers
and you're finished.
You understand me?
You're fucking finished...
[cheers and applause]
because we got each other.
And, you know, listen, man,
like Ari.
Ari's my fucking goombah
till the end.
He might be
a Jew or whatever,
and I'm Cuban,
but that's my fucking goombah.
And he knows
that's what I'm here.
Not because whatever,
but, you know,
I promised that I would be
a friend to people,
and I would
live and die for them.
And, you know,
when I look at people now,
I always look at people
sometimes and I go,
"How's that motherfucker
gonna feel when I die?"
Is he gonna be talking shit
at my funeral
or is he gonna
squeeze my daughter
and come see her every week
and give her a toy?
You know, and that's how
I have to look at people.
That's how I was raised,
you know?
And I always lived
with that guilt
of not doing something
for my friend.
And then in 2007
I got off the blow.
I quit doing cocaine.
Don't ask.
You know?
Don't clap.
Nobody's supposed to do it
anyway, you know?
People are like,
"I'm off drugs."
You're an asshole.
You're not supposed to do drugs
anyway, okay?
Don't fucking break your arm
tapping yourself on the back,
asshole.
So...
Right or wrong?
These motherfuckers walk around
with their water,
"I'm sober now."
Who gives a fuck?
You know?
You know, two months ago
you were sucking dick for rock
at The Roxy.
Now I gotta fucking
shake your hand.
Fuck you.
You motherfuckers don't know,
you know what I'm saying?
So I got off coke.
I had been off coke,
like, four days.
[laughter]
And that was tough for me.
I used to go, like,
18 hours,
and I'm like, "Ooh!"
That's a long fucking time,
you know?
I was clean for four days,
and a dear friend of mine dies.
It was a comedian.
She died of cancer.
And there was
this one producer
that used to mess with us
all the time here in L.A.
He would have these festivals
and tell us
that he was gonna book us,
and then decide,
"Oh, no, no, I'm not hiring
dirty comics this year.
Why would you have to
work so dirty?"
He'd make us feel bad
about being dirty comics,
when we were just expressing
who the fuck we were.
You know what I'm saying?
So...
I saw him then.
He had messed with
me and Marilyn a couple times,
and I saw him at the church.
Right?
I saw him at the church,
but it was 10:00.
I was a little
on the stoned side.
I said I might as well
not say nothing.
You know, sometimes
you do a bong hit before church
just to calm your nerves.
You know, sometimes
just 1 1/2 just to, you know,
just to loosen you up
before church.
And, uh...
'Cause church sucks
without a bong hit.
Trust me, that's why
it sucked as a kid.
Once you start doing bong hits,
church ain't that bad.
It's a fucking hour,
people shake hands,
they give you a cookie,
you know, everybody--
"Peace be with you,"
you know what I'm saying?
[laughs]
Right or wrong?
"Peace be with you, brother.
Peace be with you.
Peace be with you."
So that night they had
a memorial at a comedy club.
When I walk
into the memorial,
well, they had free food
at the memorial.
Like, this--
Like, they had--
They buried her that day,
but they had, like,
a microphone.
They had a picture where you're
gonna go up and say words.
Then they had free food.
When I walk in,
guess who's eating the fucking
free motherfucking food?
That motherfucking producer.
Now, by that time, I'm bre--
it's after 8:00.
The cocaine addiction
is growing.
I'm getting madder
by the minute.
I'm Cuban.
It's fucking just...
it's just developing, right?
And they come over to me,
they go, "Listen,
when we do the memorial,
can you go up on stage first?"
And I'm like, "Absolutely."
And I'll get my words over,
and I'll get
the fuck out of here
so I can go home
and go to sleep
before I choke
this motherfucker, too, right?
So they say, "Coming to
the stage, Joey Diaz."
I go on stage.
People, you know me.
I talk for like a minute,
and I can't--
this motherfucker's over there
with that smile on his face.
You know when somebody's
got, like, that smile
on their fucking face?
And in the middle of
my memorial, I just stopped.
And I go, "I don't know what
the fuck you're smiling about,
motherfucker," you know?
"But I tell you what,
"I'm gonna go get a drink,
and when I get back,
"you, your wife,
and that fucking attorney
"better get the fuck out here
'cause I'm gonna
fuck you motherfuckers up."
And I was serious, Jack.
I was fucking serious.
Like, I was done.
Like, seven days
without a line of coke.
This motherfucker--
this is my out.
I'll beat him up,
and then fuck it,
they'll throw me in county jail
for 30 days.
By the time I get out,
I'll be clean and sober.
I mean, that was my fucking...
That's how you gotta think
when you're fucking addicted,
how I was, you know?
But I was really pissed about
what this motherfucker had done
to me and to Marilyn,
and how he had the balls
to show up at this fucking wake
with that smile
on his fucking face.
And as I went to the drink,
and I came back in,
and him and his fucking family
were gone.
When I walked to my car,
I thought about one thing.
That I'm through.
I-I-I did what I had to do.
Without even knowing,
I stuck up for one of my friends
who had died.
And that night
I became that much better
as a human fucking being.
I made my peace with Z,
I made my peace
with my mother,
and most importantly
I made my peace with myself.
And that's my story
about friendship.
[cheers and applause]